glad to have you with us game two of our
double header big sam henches
takes the hill hench is coming off a
start against the detroit tigers where
he went five innings
that'll bring up vladimir guerrero jr
and he sends a smash up the middle
two is left with a stop going to his
knees rosario
gets up and amanda rosario throws him
out vladimir guerrero jr
doesn't hit anything softly steven matz
coming off a very good outing last time
out against the yankees he went six and
two thirds allowed a run on
six hits didn't walk about and struck
out ten
there's another good curveball and he
strikes out
rosario jose ramirez patting right
handed
one oh and a big cut and it's popped up
down the first baseline
richik into foul territory makes the
catch
with simeon and guerrero right alongside
good play by randall
no score after one oscar hernandez leads
off for toronto
swaying in a miss and sam hinches gets
his first strikeout he's retired the
first four in a row
i like that pitch so gretchick is aboard
with a one-out walk and lourdes guriel
to the plate and guriel can't catch up
off-speed pitch strikes him out
two k's for henches two down in the
second santiago espinal getting a start
with a left-hander on the mound
pretty good swing there by espinal a
fastball up and out over the plate and
he lines it into center for a base hit
sending grichik to second
that'll keep the inning going two on
with two out now
swung on hit high in the air to center
but
that wind blowing in will knock it down
ramirez medium deep will put it away and
so sam henches
picking up where he left off against
detroit no score middle of the second
andy rosario at first with one down owen
miller oh he's having a tough time since
coming up
again the fastball up at the top of the
zone and this time it's for strike three
called and out number two
second strikeout for max and this is
that two-seam fastball it's got so much
life on it it was such a good pitch for
him against the yankees
left on left naylor was the only indian
that did anything in game one
offensively as he swings at the first
pitch looks like it chipped the back
and the fly go to shallow right center
field grichuk will make the running
catch
and that'll be that we're scoreless
after two now the big time jam
base is loaded on a couple of walks and
a single here in the third
to oscar hernandez to clean up hitter in
dh struck out his first time up
and hernandez with a fly ball well hit
right center field
and off the wall off the top of the
fence and back in towards the infield
two runs are home and now guerrero will
score as well
it'll be a bases clearing double for t
oscar hernandez in a three to nothing
blue jay lead still just one out and now
here's randall gretchen
and he swings at the first pitch drills
it to left
and that's off the wall hernandez around
third he'll come into score
richard will take his place out at
second and it is four to nothing
boy when you give the blue jays an
opportunity look at a lot of pitches
and gauge your stuff and they can do
some damage you
chang will lead off here in the bottom
of the third indians down four
two one is swung on drill base hit
into right center field for you chang
who came in batting 145
that's the indians first hit in this
game
here's catcher renee rivera one two slow
curve over the outside corner to get him
one down
first time through the order three
strikeouts for steven mouth
and that curveball's been a good pitch
for him back to the top of the order
cesar hernandez
there's a ground ball down to first
vladi will step on the bag for one and
throw to beshet
to put the tag on chang and that is a
nifty double play to end the bottom of
the third still
four to nothing blue jays jose ramirez
the batter four nothing blue jay's
bottom four and a big high chopper to
third espinal has it
and has lots of time to throw out
ramirez harold ramirez will step
in ground ball demarcus simeon at second
on to guerrero three up three down on
groundouts for steven matt's we head to
the bottom of the pit and stephen mats
coming off a very good outing against
the yankees picking up where he left off
today against cleveland
and rosario with the one hopper down to
first guerrero with a diving play
at the bag to get the out on rosario
what a play by vlady
and rosario's so impressed he helps him
back up well what a nice play by vlady
and he just slides in head first puts
his glove on the first base back
ahead of rosario sliding into first one
down in the inning owen miller the
batter
miller strikes out swinging fourth
strikeout of the ball game
for mats on to the bottom of the six you
change leading off
then the ground ball to third
and it's going to be
[Music]
[Applause]
so the lead-off man aboard this is where
you're going to have to make some
some noise here renee rivera
with a high fly ball deep right center
field and it's going to get down
coming around third u-chain will score
and in the second with an rbi double is
rene rivera
the indians cracked the scoreboard here
in the sixth inning
four to one runners at the corners
nobody out the indians have the tying
run at the plate you know ed rosario
the pitch swung on line back up the
middle knocked down and off the glove of
the pitcher karen's to short
pachette's throw not in time base hit
rivera scores
it's a four to two ball game give
rosario an infield single he almost took
max's glove off with it and it's now
four to two
with two on nobody out and jose ramirez
is coming up
so steven matt's day concludes after the
air opened the door for cleveland and a
leg right base hit center field
they're gonna wave hernandez home here's
the throw to the plate not in time
it's a one-run game with the tying run
at third
jose ramirez with the indians fourth
consecutive hit
an rbi single to center and it's a
one-run game
here's harold ramirez and he hits a one
hopper
to second and the blue jays will turn
two
but the indians have tied the game at
four
and they'll be happy to trade that
double play
for the out the indians explode for four
and we go to the seventh emanuel klossy
on the pitch the seventh
so the go-ahead run at second with a one
out of the top of the seventh inning
back around to the top of the order to
marcus simeon
first pitch to simeon lined into center
field a base hit
davis around third will come in to score
and the blue jays have taken the lead
he has done it again simeon hasn't seen
a fastball that he doesn't like
he was all set for that heater and takes
it right back up the middle
or the bottom of the seventh how about
this three
straight walks by tyler chadwood
and the bases are loaded amen rosario
the banner one for three an rbi
single ball four it's a tie game
four straight walks in the inning
and finally charlie montoya
waves to the bullpen the winning run is
in third with only one out
anthony castro has had six inherited
runners on the year he's only allowed
one to score
jose ramirez batting left-handed
right field caught here comes zimmer
and the indians will walk it off ball
game for the indians
on a walk-off sacrifice fly to right
so the indians stun the blue jays
and win the game with two in the seventh
without the benefit of a base hit